hey guys carolyn williams here with
eight news now's digital team
this week we are talking to our on-air
talent about some really specific things
and this week the theme is jobs i'm here
with our friend chief meteorologist ted
florento
thanks for joining us hi guys happy to
be here so meteorology is a really cool
topic but did you
start off wanting to dabble in this
field
i did not uh and i think that's what
kind of happens is
uh you really never know what you really
want until you
start getting further in in your
education and everything else
this was not even on my radar no pun
intended
to even do you should be a convenience
yeah right i don't actually actually
that should be my other side job no i uh
in fact um it's just kind of funny how
it all started i yeah
i didn't want to i didn't know if i
didn't want to be a weatherman
um i didn't even know if i wanted to be
a
a tv reporter or a news anchor
but i did as a a child with my dad we
would watch
news religiously you know together
that's what he and i shared up we bonded
at
and we would watch news all the time as
a little kid and i remember
at uh i think i was eight years old
i i told my dad turned to my dad and i
said dad uh how come there aren't any
asian
men on tv uh asian men doing the news
and he said you know what ted he goes um
maybe they don't want us he goes but
maybe you can change that someday
and so i just thought about that and
went wow you know
can i really make that change is that
possible but
um that was something was on my on my
mind and then i kind of
decided to do other stuff and wanted to
become an architect i want to become
other things yeah but um i
i was trying to get into medical school
in college and then
it just didn't work out for me and then
that's when it kind of dawned on me i
remember making that promise
to my dad so then i just tried to do
everything i could to jump into uh
to tv news and that and uh that was my
calling
so and i just i have to ask you're
trying to get into medical school what
did you want to do initially when you
thought about that
uh i wanted to do a pediatric surgeon be
a pediatric surgeon
uh i wanted to help in any way i could
um but what you'll find out and a lot of
people find out in life
is you want to do something but life
throws you curveballs
you know like you think you're gonna get
that
that hit the strike zone and you miss
the strike or you get a curveball
and then you just have to pivot and and
find a different way and and i
i was the funny thing is i was i was
pretty uh down in the dumps because
that's kind of what i wanted to do
right but then my dad kicked open my
door when i
was i was like depressed for like a week
right so my dad kicks up on my door and
he goes
uh get your butt up and i said why
he goes because you weren't meant to be
a doctor
and i go okay and he goes you were meant
for something
bigger you were meant for something
greater and i go well what is that
he goes i don't know what that is but
that's for you to find out
you're meant to change the world and
you're going to do it
by not giving up so get your butt up
you can cry all you want you can depress
all you want
but you can promise me you'll never give
up right
so i said wow that's a good pep talk so
that's when i got up and i said what can
i do next and
that's when i uh decided to make that
promise i made to him
and everybody else when i was younger
and uh going into broadcasting
and you know pediatric surgeons they
save lives
they save lives but meteorologists save
lives too yeah
so you're doing something you know it's
definitely not in the same field but you
are
an important part of this community and
you guys watch ted almost every night he
brings you the latest on
all the weather whether it's a really
hot day which is these dangerous brutal
heat waves we've had lately yeah or the
monsoon season with
potentially life-threatening flooding
yeah so we're gonna go
take a look here all right guys we're
here on ted's twitter
yes and i put out a lot of tweets i
apologize
i just wanna make sure everybody's safe
so guys take a look here this is ted's
twitter and
along with tweeting all of our news he's
also tweeting
important information that people need
to know yeah
and and i like to do that like yesterday
i stayed in
uh i didn't take a dinner break i stayed
in the whole time and sat by the
radar and just put out numerous tweets i
apologize if there was a lot everyone
but
i just want to make sure everybody's
safe no apologies you know and and
that's
you you nailed it on the dot i know if i
couldn't be that surgeon but what else
can i do
i started out as a tv reporter believe
it or not first
um and i and i tell people that
uh although everybody in the newsroom
from producers to you guys on digital
to everybody else works hard because we
have a very important job
i remember as a tv reporter i had a
senior citizen a wonderful lady go ted
can you help me out
and this is when i was a reporter she
said my mailbox
her community mailbox was ripped out and
stolen
and they have didn't nobody was was
fixing it at all was on top of it she
said she's been waiting for like a week
she goes can you help us out at all and
help me out in any way
so i made a call to the us usps
um and um you know let them know like
you know
this is a story it really is
and if we don't get on top of it it's
definitely a story that we got to do
because
it's our job to help people and get the
word out to help those people that
that can't get the help and uh sure
enough
she got her mailbox uh literally the
next day
that's great so if we as reporters
uh didn't make that effort for you guys
and you submitting stories to us
who knows when she got that mailbox so
we have very important jobs as reporters
they have a very important job as a
meteorologist because
while storms are out there you
you really need to get the heads up on
and these are these are deadly storms so
it's it's
a very important job to let everybody
know what's going on and um
in the meteorology field you can come up
with again some really hard challenges
like mother nature does
not she will not do what you think she
does all the time she'll change at the
very last second what are some of the
challenges that you face every day well
that's that's the
the thing you run into is you you can
you can kind of forecast that we're
gonna get some thunderstorms that day
but pinpointing exactly where they're
gonna pop up at is really difficult yeah
which is why you like battleship yeah
you're really happy
you suck my battle [ __ ] that's it that's
absolutely right
that's the tough part is is trying to
figure out where these thunderstorms are
going to fire up and that's where
experience kind of comes up you know
like
one storm will pop up and then you'll go
okay send some gusts of wind over to las
vegas while we're feeling it
well those gusts of winds are outflows
and that could actually start up new
ones
so when you start to see one start a
cell start to get a little bigger like
let's say for example nellis you're like
okay that one's gonna get bigger
uh so these are things where you just
have to sit by the radar and experience
is
is necessary and um you know i you know
decade over decade experience to almost
two decades experience of
up um meteorology so uh
that's what that plays and and helps you
out
you know and um some meteorologists they
have
specific weather types that they focus
on like severe
hurricane winter what is your favorite
type of weather to cover well i think
my favorite honestly are um
hurricanes um i when i took my
meteorology courses i was really really
into hurricanes
uh unfortunately um i'm more of an
expert
at covering snow because i've been in so
many snow locations like
i covered snow in green bay i covered
snow in philly i covered snow in yakima
washington eastern washington
um and and we don't get much snow here
but you know when we when we do have
those snow days here
i'm on top of it because i have such
expensive greens on it right
but uh hurricanes are are they're the
funnest to cover
but they're also the scariest too
carolyn because
with a with a tornado it and i've done
i've done tornado chasing too
it hits and it's out of here but your
hurricane can last
all day like all day which is why
sometimes the roofs
can't take it because the winds have
just been going all day the roof just
says i can't hang on anymore and
it's gone yep so uh those are the
funnest i know so much about hurricanes
so
when they have you mentioned hurricanes
here i'm like absolutely yeah do a whole
thing on storm surge whatever you want
yeah
so those are fun but thunderstorms are
always fun for me
um because as long as you know we're
safe because flash flooding of course is
dangerous and deadly
so and um going back to your dad's pep
talk
when you were younger you go to schools
and you speak to students about
career futures your field yeah
tell us a little bit about that well
it's funny because what
everyone needs to realize is my dad had
really my dad was
was was very wise you know and uh
he gave me some really good pep talks um
i remember
when um when i when i graduated with my
my degree broadcast journalism degree
i said okay now i'm ready to take on the
world and become that first
asian you know or one of the very few
asian
males doing uh doing news in general
uh i'm really the only one doing weather
you know i mean i was the only one in
philadelphia i was the only one in
in green bay wisconsin i'm the only one
here you know
so i'm still trying to make that mark
for others but what i
would uh what i ran into was i was
sending out
so many resumes and so many but we made
videotapes of ourselves back then
and to all these news directors and my
friends were all getting hired but i
wasn't getting hired
and i was like man maybe they maybe
they're not ready for an
asian you know news anchor or asian
meteorologist and my dad goes here's the
deal
he goes i want you to send a thousand
more and he goes
remember he goes you're gonna lose
you're gonna fail
you're gonna cry your eyes out you're
getting depressed
but that's okay because you can always
fail you're always gonna lose you're
always gonna get rejected
but you will never ever give up
promise me no matter what happens you'll
never give up
i do this when i go speak at schools i
give the same speech and i still get
choked up
and yeah it's a great great advice right
and look at you now
you are someone who people depend on
every day here in vegas you have made
strides i just knew like i just knew
okay and what he i knew like what he
told me was
you know you could send out a thousand
tips thousand resumes and he goes
all you need he goes is just one i just
need one person to say yes
i don't care it's a thousand and that
one person was mike paul millie and
yakima
gave me a chance to work for him for
free for
for i think it was like a month two
months i just
worked my butt off for free i went in
early right
in the morning and then i left i would
leave late editing my own stuff shooting
my own stuff
and then i thought to myself i said is
mike watching is he actually watching me
coming in or not and i went you know
what
it doesn't matter if he's watching or
not knowing that i'm coming in early and
leaving late that's what matters
and the universe is going to work itself
out so i would do that all the time
and i just remember in june he goes you
know what
i see you've been working hard um i want
to hire you
because i saw you come in early
man this is great this is way back in 99
yeah and he goes uh i see you early and
i see you leaving late
i want to give you a job so so here i am
that's awesome yeah so great and you
you are awesome and you have this you
have a video that you like to show
when you go to these schools yeah i like
i go to these schools and uh
because i let these kids know like you
know
i come from three brothers uh there's
three of us
and uh both of my older brothers were
straight a students like right
like to the t uh i'll be honest i was
never the straight a student i was more
the c student
i kind of kidded around a lot right but
one thing they always said
was that you were always when you wanted
something you never gave up you just
went after it
and you didn't even hesitate you just
went and that's what i try to get to
these
kids and see how you're going to fail
you're going to lose but
that doesn't mean anything you know so
um
my brothers would go yeah i want to do
this but
there's like three things that could go
wrong with it and i'd go yeah but
there's like three things that could go
right
because it gets tough why do i
show yeah i still don't speak these
schools i still get the wide words
get choked up so that was always my
thinking and uh
because of it um i'm here today and and
um you know i try to get that to the
kids
but yeah i just want to show you this
video because i show this at the schools
because this kind of lets you know
about like life will throw your
curveballs and that's okay you just
you just gotta roll with the curveballs
and just keep going so
this has come from uh facing the giants
um it's called never
never give up don't quit kids these days
sometimes it's hard to get a job
out of college and it's feels really
easy to give up
but if people remember things like that
cliff just showed us things like your
dad told us yeah
they can achieve incredibly amazing
things like you have
it's it's so easy to give up and i i
could have given up too
but um like my dad said you know you
sent out
you know you sent out 300 resumes and
you all got rejections
but that means you send out 300 more and
you send in another 300 more
there's a couple things that also that i
did that i think worked in everybody's
favor
in the news business was um i got an
agent
um to get me to another market
and he did the best he could to give me
the bigger markets from here
um but i said you know what i'm gonna
take the initiative i know i pay him but
why don't i take the initiative
so i would email the news directors or
the bosses that you need to
myself and i found out that
the news director in philadelphia was
like oh i got your tape before but now
that you message
me now because with your other agents
i'm getting numerous
numerous videos but since you messaged
me
i'm going to really look at yours and he
goes you know what i want to hire you
if i did not do that i would have been
put in the mix with everybody else so
um that's one thing you do is you have
you have to take the
initiative and and do that sometimes
even if you hired somebody to do it for
you
there's no harm in that and it's not
going to hurt you any doing that
yeah well ted that was awesome thank you
so much
thank you for having me i really
appreciate it um guys
we will have several other stories like
that we also have chris matthews and
nate tannebaum so you don't want to miss
their installations of this as well
thanks so much we'll see you guys later
take care guys
[Music]